and the hill reports that CEO of Equifax
has been called to testify before
Congress the company is under intense
pressure to explain how hackers stole
the personal data of as many as 143
million Americans the House Energy and
Commerce Committee yesterday sent a
letter asking the CEO Richard Smith to
appear early next month about 40 state
attorneys general also investigating and
awareness but with two of them and a
good morning good morning Charlie
equifax says it has hired an independent
cybersecurity firm to determine the
extent of the hack since revealing this
massive security breach the company has
been blasted by angry consumers and a
variety of state and federal officials
who all want answers this is the most
egregious data breach we have ever seen
it is as bad as it gets
Massachusetts attorney general Maura
Healey says she will sue Equifax for
violating state consumer protection laws
if you're a company like Equifax and
you're out there scooping up a whole
bunch of data and information on people
we have laws on our books that say you
have to protect that information Eric
Schneiderman New York's Attorney General
may file a lawsuit as well
he says credit reporting agencies don't
face the same scrutiny as banks
hospitals and others that handle
confidential consumer data I think
you're gonna see changes to the industry
as well as investigations as to whether
the company and any individuals engaged
in illegal activity Equifax discovered
it was hacked in July but only went
public last week sensitive data like
birth dates Social Security and driver's
license numbers were compromised this is
really an attack on our whole economic
system on Wednesday Mark Warner vice
chairman of the Senate Intelligence
Committee urged the Federal Trade
Commission to investigate right now we
have 49 different laws around the
country we need a single law Warner is
one of 37 senators from both parties who
also asked the FTC the Justice
Department and the Securities and
Exchange Commission to look into
possible insider trading three Equifax
executives sold nearly two million
dollars in companies stock days after
the data breach was discovered
Equifax says those of
officials were not aware of the hack
many consumers requested to freeze their
credit but that may not be enough but
there are other types of identity theft
and a credit freeze will not lock the
thieves out of that type of behavior
well Equifax says they are intensely
investigating the intrusion and working
with law enforcement as part of their
investigation Nora all right Anna thank
you so much for that report